HE HAS NO CLUE WHAT IS HAPPENING
HAPPENING.
>> Sean: MORE ON MY MONOLOGUE
IN JUST A MOMENT.
JOINING US NOW, THE AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK "LIBERAL PRIVILEGE."
CONGRATS ON YOUR FIRST NUMBER
ONE BEST SELLER.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> DONALD TRUMP JR.
1800 QUESTIONS VERSUS 34.
1803F I’M GOING TO BE EXACT.
BASED ON MY COUNT, I MIGHT BE A
LITTLE OFF.
I DON’T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER.
HE’S RUNNING AGAINST A GHOST.
>> 100%, SEAN, AND THAT’S THE
REASON I WROTE THE BOOK "LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE."
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE.
YOU CAN HAVE A CANDIDATE THAT
WANTS TO REPLACE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE REFUSES TO SPEAK TO ANYONE IN
THE PRESS.
HE’S INCAPABLE OF GETTING
THROUGH A PRESS CONFERENCE.
WHEN HE SPEAKS TO A GROUP OF TEN
PEOPLE HE NEEDS A TELEPROMPTER
AND HE STILL MESSES THAT
APPEARED BY THE WAY, NO ONE IN
THE PRESS SAYS ANYTHING.
OH, IT’S PERFECTLY NORMAL.
WHEN YOU HAVE CLEAR COGNITIVE
DECLINE LIKE THIS, THIS GUY IS
SOMEHOW A MODERATE.
BUT YOU ARE NOT A MODERATE IF
YOU ARE OPPOSING BETO O’ROURKE.
YOU ARE NOT A MODERATE IF YOU
ARE WITH KAMALA HARRIS WHO HAS
THE MOST LIBERAL RECORD IN THE
SENATE.
YOU ARE NOT A MODERATE IF YOU
ARE ON BERNIE SANDERS UNITY
PLATFORM ON YOUR WEBSITE.
IT’S THE COMMUNIST MANIFESTO OF
THE NEW AGE, SEAN.
THERE IS NOTHING MODERATE ABOUT
BIDEN, SEAN, BECAUSE THE MEDIA
IS GOING TO GIVE HIM BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF FREE COVERAGE
HIDING THE 50 YEARS OF BAD
DECISIONS THAT HE HAS MADE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT IS NOT ME SAYING IT.
THAT’S ROBERT GATES.
OBAMA’S OWN SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
WHO LITERALLY SAID THAT HE HAS
BEEN ON THE WRONG SIDE OF EVERY
DECISION IN HIS POLITICAL
CAREER.
THAT IS LITERALLY SAYING
SOMETHING.
THAT’S IMPRESSIVE.
A MONKEY GUESSING AT RANDOM
COULD HAVE PERFORMED BETTER THAN
JOE BIDEN IN TERMS OF MAJOR
DECISIONS FOR AMERICA.
I HAVEN’T EVEN STARTED TALKING
ABOUT HOW HE BUILT UP CHINA.
>> Sean: SOMETIMES HE CONFUSES
THE DAY OF THE WEEK, THE OFFICE
HE’S RUNNING FOR.
SEEMS TO FORGET THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY ENDOWED BY NOT THE
THING.
WHERE WAS HE WITH CORONAVIRUS
TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST KNOWN
CASE IN AMERICA?
HE WAS CALLING A TRAVEL BAN, THE
FIRST QUARANTINE IN 60 YEARS.
AND THEN THE LARGEST IN HISTORY.
HYSTERICAL, XENOPHOBIC, AND
FEARMONGERING.
WHERE HAS HE BEEN?
IT’S HARD TO WATCH.
WE HAVE MORE COMING UP.
THIS GUY BEAT NEARLY TO DEATH.
WHERE IS JOE?
>> THE SOLUTION FOR THAT IS TO
DEFUND THE POLICE, REALLOCATE
SOCIAL WORKERS.
BLM IS DESTROYING DEMOCRAT-RUN
CITIES.
THESE ARE CITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
CONTROLLED BY DEMOCRATS FOR UP
TO A CENTURY.
THIS IS THE QUINTESSENTIAL
EXAMPLE OF LIBERAL PRIVILEGE.
IT SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING.
IT CANNOT BE GOING ON IN
AMERICA.
GUESS WHAT?
IT IS NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
THESE BIG CITIES.
IT’S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME UNTIL
THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE LITERALLY
SIDING WITH CRIMINALS UNTIL THIS
COMES INTO YOUR BACKYARD, SEAN.
IT’S INEVITABLE.
THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF PUSHING
BACK AGAINST THE BAD GUYS.
>> Sean: I CANNOT BELIEVE HE
IS ALLOWED TO STAY SILENT.
THE MEDIA, THEY HAVE SMEARED,
SLANDERED.
THEY ARE INVOLVED IN CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND HOAXES.
AFTER NOT ONLY THAT, BUT AS MUCH
COLLATERAL DAMAGE AS THEY CAN
TAKE.
THEY RUINED CARTER PAGE’S LIFE
FOR FOUR YEARS.
ALSO GENERAL FLYNN’S LIFE.
>> BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> Sean: YEAH.
AND I’M WONDERING.
>> THERE IS NO ONE THEY WON’T
DESTROY TO GET THEIR WAY, SEAN.
THERE IS NO ONE THEY WON’T
DESTROY TO GET THEIR WAY.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID TO MAKE
SAND MEN, WHO WAS A 15-YEAR-OLD
KID.
HIS CRIME, BEING A MALE
CONSERVATIVE FROM THE SOUTH WHO
SUPPORTS TRUMP AND HAPPENS TO BE
A CHRISTIAN.
THOUGHTS AN OFFENSE TODAY IN THE
EYES OF THE DEMOCRATS.
IT’S NO LONGER OKAY TO CERTAINLY
BE APOLITICAL.
YOU MUST BE WOKE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IF YOU ARE
WOKE TODAY, BY TOMORROW YOU ARE
NO LONGER WALK.
THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON.
THEY ARE RUN BY LUNATICS.
THE LEFT, THE MOST LUNATIC OF
THE LUNATICS, THEY ARE THE
THOUGHT LEADERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THOSE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE PULLING JOE BIDEN’S
PURSE STRINGS.
HE HAS BEEN A PUPPET FOR A LONG
TIME.
BUT IF YOU DON’T THINK THAT HE
IS, IF YOU THINK HE’S THE SAME
GUY, ALL YOU NEED TO DO IS GET
ON YOUTUBE AND WATCH A VIDEO OF
HIM 15 YEARS AGO.
LOOK AT THAT AND LOOK AT THE GUY
TODAY AND TELL ME THEY ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT THEY
CAN TRY TO SELL AMERICA TO
JOE BIDEN AS BEING MODERATE.
HE’S NOT.
IT’S A LIE.
YOU NEED TO EDUCATE YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU GO VOTE.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS IN THIS
GAME.
THEY DON’T EVEN PRETEND ANYMORE
TO BE OBJECTIVE.
THEY ARE LIBERAL ACTIVISTS.
AND THAT’S IT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT,
DONALD TRUMP JR. APPEARED BY THE
WAY, IT MAY NOT BE A GOOD WEEK
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY TO
WATCH.
JUST SAYING.
THERE’S ONLY SO MUCH.
>> I HAVE TO, SEAN.
IT’S COMICAL RELIEF.
IT’S COMICAL RELIEF AT THIS
POINT.
>> Sean: IT’S COMICAL, BUT
I’VE GOT TO BE HONEST.
IF THEIR STATED POLICIES
DONALD TRUMP JR. EVER
IMPLEMENTED, IT’S OVER.
>> 100%.
YOU, YOU THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF SPENDING
$4 TRILLION.
YOU DON’T GET THAT FOR YOUR OWN
FAMILY BUT YOU CAN PAY FOR
THEIRS.
EDUCATION.
HOW IS IT FOR CRIMINALS COMING
OUT OF PRISON?
YOU CAN PAY FOR THAT, BUT YOU
DON’T GET IT FOR YOURSELF AND